CAN'T PUT MYSELF IN THAT
SITUATION TO GIVE THEM THAT
ABILITY TO DO THAT.
SO I HAVE THE LOOK AT MYSELF AND
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE BETTER, AND
IT IS A TOUGH TIME.
SO, WE HAVE TO CLEAN UP.
>> THAT IS ENOUGH.
>> I HAVE TO LOOK AT THE FILM,
AND FIGURE IT OUT.
IT WAS LIKE A BLUR TONIGHT.
>> SO THERE WAS MORE ON CHRIS
PAUL'S MIND THAN THE GAME
AFTERWARDS AND FINING PLAYERS
FOR SAYING STUFF, BUT THE FANS
CAN PUT THEIR HANDS ON OUR
FAMILY, AND THEN SAID THAT FANS
PUT THEIR HANDS ON OUR FAMILIES,
AND PAUL'S KIDS WITNESSED IT AND
FELT UNSAFE THE SOURCE SAID.
AND NOW, THE SOURCE FOR THE
DALLAS MAVS, AND THE INCIDENT
BETWEEN THE FAN AND CHRIS PAUL'S
FAMILY, AND IT IS UNACCEPTABLE,
AND THE MAVS WITH
AMERICANAIRLINES CENTER SWIFTLY
REMOVED THE FAN FROM TODAY'S
GAME.
SHAQ, YOU WANT TO WEIGH IN?
>> THE WAY TO DO THAT IS THAT WE
HAVE COUSIN, AND IF YOU GO INTO
THE HOSTILE ARENA, YOU WATCH MY
WIFE AND MY MAMA, AND IF SOMEONE
TOUCHES THEM, YOU HAVE MY
PERMISSION TO TOUCH THEM UP.
AND YOU CANNOT EXPECT OUR WIVES
AND MOTHERS TO BE THERE TO ENJOY
THE GAME, AND PEOPLE ARE
BULLYING THEM, AND POOH DOG AND
MOOKIE WAS THERE, AND THEY HAD
MY PERMISSION TO WATCH MS.
LUCILLE, AND THAT IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN.
>> THERE IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
SOMEONE WHO GETS LIQUORED UP,
AND, SO --
>> WELL, THEY PUT HANDS ON THEM.
>> AND THEY COULD HAVE PUT HANDS
ON THEM, TOO.
AND SO I DON'T WANT TO ACCUSE
PEOPLE BASED ON THE CRAP ON THE
INTERNET, BUT YOU ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO PUT YOUR HANDS ON
ANYBODY, BUT I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED, BUT WHEN YOU GOING
INTO THE HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT,
THERE IS ALWAYS SOME LIQUORED UP
FANS, AND I HAVE ALWAYS SAID,
HEY, WE COULD PUT AN END TO ALL
OF THIS STUFF, AND SOL OF THE
STUFF THAT THE FANS SAY, LET'S
TAKE THEM RIGHT DOWN THERE IN
THE CENTER COURT BY FIVE MINUTE,
AND I HAVE SAID THAT, SOME OF
THE CRAP THEY SAID TO YOU, HEY,
JUST GIVE ME FIVE MINUTES AT THE
CENTER COURT WITH YOU, AND YOU
AIN'T GOING TO PRESS NO CHARGES,
AND NOBODY, AND HEY, AIN'T
NOBODY GOING TO BE SUED CIVILLY
AND SAY WHAT YOU SAID TO MY
FACE, AND FOR FIVE MINUTES, AM
GOING TO BEAT YOUR ASS.
>> IT WILL TAKE FIVE MINUTES?
>> NO, I AM NOT GOING BEAT THEM
QUICKLY, I AM GOING TO JAB THEM
A LITTLE BIT AND THEN LAY THE
HAYMAKERS ON THEIR ASS.
>> I HEAR YOU CHARLES FOREMAN.
>> AND IN THE REAL SOCIETY OTHE
BECAUSE, YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE
PEOPLE ARE COMING FROM.
YOU HAVE 20,000 PEOPLE AROUND
10.
AND YOU KNOW HOW, YOU KNOW I
ALWAYS WONDER HOW THOSE MOB
THINGS HAPPEN, AND THEN
EVERYBODY JOIN IN.
SO ANY TIME YOU BRING YOUR
FAMILY OR ANYBODY ON THE ROAD,
YOU NEED TO TALK TO SECURITY, A
FIRST OF ALL, TEAM SHOULD SEND
SECURITY WITH YOU ANYWAY.
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT.
YOU NEVER TAKE YOUR FAMILY AND
KID, AND I AM TAKING MY BODY
GUARD WITH ME OR I WILL HAVE A
GROWN MAN THERE TO PROTECT THEM,
BECAUSE, ERNIE, SOME OF THIS
STUFF, AND WHEN I PLAYED FOR THE
76ers SOME OF THE STUFF THEY
WOULD SHOUT AT OUR TEAM WAS
BRUTAL.
I GOT A GUY WHO GOT TWO QUICK
FOULS, AND I CAN'T STAND WHAT
THEY SAID TO ME, AND I JUST
CAN'T HANDLE THE PRESSURE, AND
THEY ARE SCREAMING AND TALKING
ABOUT MY MOM AND MY KIDS, AND
WHEN I GET THEM TWO QUICK FOULS
AND GO TO BENCH, THEY LEAVE